ILDREN OF ALMI GACE DIINDIES ORF
INCLUDINBLE TREATM
JOININ N ABOUT THE
FIGS DISEARCHER WHO OAW
EW
ANINWITH
EO, FROM THE OFE END OFACSPECIA.
VT MES OF LIFE ALE WAY TOLAST E
IF A KID BREAKS HIS ARM TUNGOR F
LESS LIKELY TO GET THE
PAINKILLERS.
EXAIHERE
BS
THERE HAS BEENO MUCHESH EMMENTAT
ENTOE REPLACED ARE LESLIGE UNAT.
S CLE WHY?>> S T A OIS PARITIEA
RACISM AND ILIND
TET ONLYN YO STY B
WE NEED TOESEAH TO
RS EXAEINGHIS, BUT ONE OF ID IN.
THE
T THEY ND
THAT AF THE CHILDREN HAD ONRE
INSURANCD TILL SEEING
THARITIES.
>>EY HADTHLSOMSED ON THE COMMUN
WHICH THEY LIVE OR THEOFR FAMIL.
THE MORE WORK IN
THIS SCESE WE KNOWT
EVEN THOUGH CHIL
INSURANCE, ALL INSURANCE INOT S.
SO IF YOVE PUBLIC E
OROUE COCICE
OR PRIVATE INSURERE ARE SO THERT
THOUGH YOU HANSANCE YP QUALITC
HN PERSISTED.E, THE DISPARIT R
SO WHAT SEEMED TO REALLYE
IVS HE WERE RA  IS AGAIN VE FOR
AND LAST F THE MTCHING ATH
W DO THEY AT
>>BSOLUTELY.
I THINK THER BA I DON'T WANTREHE
D  LITHEAV
HEART ANSAO
KID NEEDS CA, I NE
AND THEN TIN
WITH TLT
SO THERE AREHINGS AT
AND CAREGIVERS C D
HE CHID BESTT HEALTH CARE SYSTET
REEW POLICIE AE 'RE
T EXACERBATINGR MAKING
DIARS  WORSEFO
AND FOR D POTICIANS CA TO MA
THESINBYG INOMND TRE ARE